معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نبدا معك نجوان بهذا الخبر العاجل
الذي ادعنا قبل قليل عن اصابه 19 جنديا
اسرائيليا في الساعات ال4 الماضيه وفق ما
اعلنه جيش الاحتلال هل هنالك من
تفاصيل نعم بالفعل وفقا لاخر تحديث في
موقع الجيش الاسرائيلي فمنذ يوم امس او
خلال الساعات الاربع والعش الماضيه اضيف
19 جنديا جريحا وفقا لقوائم ال الجيش
ونقلوا الى المستشفيات لتلقي ال العلاج
وا بالعاده زين العابدين المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه التي تستقبل هؤلاء الجنود
المصابين تنشر اي عن هذه الاعداد في ساعات
ال المساء اي الاعداد عاده لدى المستشفيات
تكون اعلى من الاعداد التي يعلن عنها
الجيش الا الاسرائيلي تحديدا فيما يتعلق
بالاصابات الخطيره اي ومستشفى سوروكا على
سبيل المثال اكبر المستشفيات في منطقه
الجنوب في مدينه بئر السبع وهو المستشفى
الذي استقبل اكبر عدد من المصابين الجنود
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب يتحدث عن اعداد عن
مجمل اعداد الاصابات هي قريبه لما يتحدث
عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل عام بمعنى ان
هناك مستشفيات عده استقبلت الجنود ابرزها
سوروكا وايضا برزيلاي في مدينه عسقلان في
المناطق القريبه من غلاف غزه وعندما
ينشرون مجمل اعداد الاصابات تكون اكثر
بكثير مما ينشره الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل
عام قبل اسبوع
اي بشكل عام نعم قبل اسبوع كانت هناك كان
هناك تقرير في صحيفه دعوت احرونوت
تحدث عما وصفها بالصوره القاتمه جدا فيما
يت تعلق بعدد الاصابات ونوعيه الاصابات
تحديدا بعد زيارات للمستشفيات التي
استقبلت وقدمت العلاج
لهؤلاء الاسرى وهناك توقعات ان يتجاوز عدد
المصابين في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي وفقا
لهذا التقرير ممن اصبحت لديهم اعاقه دائمه
جراء بتر بالاطراف او ى في البصر اكثر من
12000 جنديا وهناك توقف ان تصل اعداد من
سيقدمون بين الجنود طلبات للاعتراف بهم
كمعاق في الجيش الاسرائيلي الى ما لا يقل
عن 20 الف جنديا واشار في حينه الكاتب الى
ان الاعداد التي يقدمها الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي مختلفه الى حد كبير عما تقدمه
المستشفيات وجهات رسميه اخرى تتعامل مع
الجنود الجرحى سواء كان قسم اعاده تاهيل
الج جنود في وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وايضا ما يعرف بمنظمه معاقي الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي من الواضح ان هناك
امور لا يعلن عنها الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق تحديدا بعدد اصابات
الجنود احد ال المحللين الاسرائيليين كنت
قد سالته لماذا يعني هذا الاختلاف بين ما
يعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي من عدد لاصابات
الجنود وبين العدد الذي تحدث عنه هذه
الجهات سواء كان المستشفيات او الاطقم
الطبيه التي في جيش الاحتياط ممن يقدمون
العلاج للجنود في الميدان او جهات اخرى
فقال انه لو لو اصبح الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي يتحدث بشفافيه عن مجريات سير
هذه الحرب سواء كان على صعيد سير العمليات
العسكريه او على صعيد الاصابات ونوعيه هذه
الاصابات بين الجنود لكانت بدا هناك حراك
ا اكبر في اسرائيل سيطالب بوقف هذه الحرب
ولذلك هناك نوع من التكتم والتستر على
كثير من المعلومات وهذا فقط ما يصل الى
الصحافه بمعنى قد يكون ان هناك امور اخرى
يتم اخفاؤها بطبيعه الحال او عدم نشرها في
هذه المرحله الى ربما ما بعد الحرب وفقا ل
سياسات امنيه متبعه عاده في اسرائيل تاجيل
الكثير من الامور الى ما بعد بعد الحرب
كالتحكم الحاسبات
ايضا في كل سير هذه العمليات وتحديدا ما
يتعلق في
الس نعم نعم عندما نتحدث عن اعداد
المصابين وهذه الفجوه الهائله بين ما
ينشره الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما يتحدث الجيش
عن مجمل اصاباته منذ بدايه الحرب وحتى
اليوم بعدد يساوي تقريبا عدد الاصابات في
واحده فقط من المستشفيات فهذا يعني الكثير
يعني هناك عدد كبير من المستشفيات في
مدينه تل ابيب في القدس وفي عسقلان وفي
بئر السبع استقبلوا جنود جنودا مصابين
والجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن مجمل الاعداد
تساوي الاعداد التي استقبلتها او استقبلها
مستشفى واحد وبالتالي من الواضح ان هناك
فجوات وهذا ما يتحدث عنه الاعلام
الاسرائيلي يعني هذه معلومات
موثقه الصحفيه للجرحى من جنود الاحتلال في
المستشفيات ذكرينا به مره
اخرى قبل اسبوع كان الحديث يدور عن ان
هناك ما لا يقل عن 6000 جندي تم تعامل
معهم من قبل المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
المختلفه ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني لو
نظرنا الى فقط ما نشره قبل قليل الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي وفقا لاخر تحديث له
لراي ان مجمل الاصابات التي يتحدث عنها
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه هذه الحرب هي
2438 اصابه وهذا في اخر تحديث له في موقعه
وهو تقريبا يساوي ما نشرته يوم امس على
سبيل المثال مستشفى سوروكا من اعداد
للمصابين الذين استقبلوا وتم تقديم العلاج
لهم في هذا المستشفى ومره اخرى سروك هو
مستشفى واحد فقط
قدم العلاج للجنود المصابين لكن هناك عدد
كبير اخر من المستشفيات مثل برزيلاي
ومستشفيات اخوف
و شيبا ايضا في تل ابيب بالاضافه الى
مستشفيات اخرى في مدينه القدس منها هداس
وكنا قد راينا العديد من المروحيات
العسكريه التابعه لفرق القا لفرقه الانقاذ
الخاصه المعروفه ب 669 وهي تقل جنودا من
ارض المعركه وتحط في عدد من هذه مستشفيات
كانت هناك فيديوهات من هداس وفيديوهات من
اخوف وايضا من روكا دعني فقط اشير الى هذه
هذه الانفجارات التي نسمعها منذ ساعات
الصباح في هذه المناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه هذه المناطق التي اعلن الجيش بانه
تقريبا انهى القتال الواسع وعمليات القصف
فيها ولكن بين الحين والاخر نسمع قصف
مدفعي يستهدف عدد من المواقع في المناطق
الشماليه وايضا صوت انفجارات طيله الوقت
جرا
مواصله الجيش بتفجير عدا المنازل التي لم
تتدمر كليا خلال عمليات القصف زين
العابدين شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري من
غلاف غز